now firefighters are battling more than
100 wildfires burning across
russia's siberia the fires are more
intense this year due to high
temperatures and a prolonged drought
it is feared the fires could
significantly damage the region's
ecosystem it's hard to comprehend the
scale of these fires
they've torn their way through more than
1.5 million hectares of land in the
region of
yakutia leaving scorched earth in their
and the fire season is only just
beginning
thousands of firefighters are working
around the clock
to get the blazers under control
if not for the strong winds we could do
it faster but you see how strong the
winds are
that's our biggest problem right now
that wind is driving the smoke to the
eastern siberian city of yakutsk
famous for being the coldest city on
earth
usually pictured blanketed in snow not
smoke
residents here are alarmed
she's just a child and she tells me
herself grandma let's close the windows
because it's difficult for me to breathe
i don't know what this is
although forest fires in summer are
normal here their ferocity this year is
being blamed on unusually high
temperatures
along with smoke they've also been
spewing out record amounts of greenhouse
gases
scientists fear that this will further
accelerate climate change
in one of earth's most fragile regions